how long do you think people keep the
New Year's resolutions to
two weeks two weeks according to my gym
membership yeah about a month
to find out on this episode of LED live
[Music]
Darkness Happy New Year we hope you guys
are having a blessed holiday season and
obviously depending on when you're
seeing this uh video it's gonna be 2023.
yeah so future it's the future it's the
future so we want to be the first to
wish you guys a Happy New Year we had an
awesome year at Little Light Studios
this year some huge Milestones that we
hit this was a good year for us we
crossed over to 150 000 subscribers that
is really neat I mean as we've looked
back over some of this the stats uh
We've grown doubled our Facebook isn't
that right yes overdoubled so we have
over 50 000 extra followers now so we've
crossed over to 106.00 that's all thanks
to you guys thank you guys and you know
more so than numbers
um just the testimonies that have poured
in over this last year has just
encouraged me and this is just an
awesome awesome year yeah I love our
team too man our team has grown so much
we've been able to do a lot more like
the thing that candy did the Black
Panther thing because of the help of
Micah and Michael and just all of us
kind of thrown in a little bit it was
really cool I like how you know there's
a time when
maybe like Magic Kingdom for instance
you pretty much did all of it right
it was done
in the middle of the night and I was
speaking quiet
because my kids were in the Next Room
over there and so you know I had this
little office that was just outside of
my kid's room and and it's been neat to
see from that project to what we've got
going on now is pretty pretty
drastically different that is awesome
and now it's like everybody kind of has
something that they do whereas you were
like this you scored you did everything
you narrated it you edited it and now
it's kind of like oh pass it off to the
green screen team or whatever it is neat
we have a beautiful team and each has a
unique gift to bring to the table and we
just wanted to thank you guys for all
your love and support over the years and
uh but this conversation I want to talk
a little bit about New Year's
resolutions okay anybody do those
yeah it's usually about weight loss yeah
weight loss okay anyone else want to
admit you have a resolution have you
ever written it out
never never it's probably like a serious
little project or something yeah just
you have to see it you know to a vision
board yeah when I started working in
this ministry in 2008 I wrote in New
Year's resolution and and I can remember
looking at it years later and on that
resolution I said I want to make a
feature length documentary every year
wow and it's like now we've been able to
like you know expand that we've put out
hundreds of pieces of content on YouTube
and and so I kind of I think it's
interesting to look at what you I I said
I said out I wanted to do and all of a
sudden it's like getting done it's
really neat uh 2013 I made a New Year's
resolution I got to surrender all mind
altering chemicals and god Set Me Free
and woke up no withdrawals for Weed and
Alcohol and never looked back so that's
definitely one that stuck out my mind on
New Year's resolution that I made and
stuck with but it's all thanks to praise
God praise God all right so I want to
hear from you guys what do you think is
the is the list of let's say the top
five or ten resolutions that everybody
has take a guess what do you think are
this top five
things that people wait a minute
exercise yeah exercise money management
money management
um
probably sleep or something with
lifestyle like
yeah or is it like a hobby like like
okay a hobby that's on one of them a new
careers what was that for
I remember seeing a lot of like maybe
travel that was up on the list a few
times a few times on the same list well
I mean like a few different lists like
they've actually done studies I'm going
to show you a couple of studies in just
a second
um but anybody else want to take a guess
what else is on there
so we got food money exercise uh travel
faith maybe a relationship with God poor
family that's interesting that Alex just
said that keep that in mind we're going
to cover that but faith in God
actually wasn't on any list that I saw
I'm not surprised it wasn't
um so here's a list of the most popular
ones this was a study that was done by
14 and a half thousand people I'd say
that's a pretty good sizable study
saving money was one of the most popular
ones yeah losing weight doing more
exercise involving
um my I don't know is that that actually
uh doing more exercises wait but maybe
also Health diet uh pursuing some sort
of career ambition spending more time
with the family that's that's a that's a
really good one but look at how that's
like way down on the list right it's
like money's the top thing people want
to care about but then look weight diet
and exercise those all weight I know I
was thinking according to the first five
or six we're all uh fat money wasters
that don't have any time that
Workaholics welcome to the United States
okay so I'm glad that you brought that
up right there so you gotta you got a
good idea of what people are giving up
smoking giving up porn giving up
drinking giving up some other things
um look at this one this is the statista
and this is what they they the different
study but this is what they came out
with exercise more was sort of on the
top of their list
healthier lose weight spend more time
with friends spend less time on social
media I thought that was interesting
yeah like like I think people people
realize that it's a big time waster I
mean 20 of people you know recognizing
that that's a problem is is very
interesting and yeah reducing stress at
work hey we have a documentary on that
called hashtag selfie if you guys want
to check that out that's right okay so
this is this is uh that's that so let's
look at a different country
this is from 2019 in England this is
what they came up with as well so it's
not just our country that's actually
hidden in fact if you look at these
lists from all around the world there's
kind of the same things that we're all
worried about and we're all talking
about we're vain we want to look nice
yeah yeah yeah yeah but are there any
other countries we got one body man we
got to take care of this yeah but don't
you think it's interesting that God is
not on here that is very interesting I
mean on a lot of the lists that I looked
at I mean we supposedly live in a
Christian Nation and you would think
that that would be you know like needing
to spend more time read the Bible read
the Bible or something like that you
know something that's wholesome and good
I I don't know I think you know if you
didn't know anything about our culture
you would look at this and be like oh
these these people are obsessed with
their looks their money their you know
Health to be healthy that's a good thing
but not so much their God yeah yeah very
interesting well anybody got any
things that inspired you this year as
you look back over the last year is
there is there is there a story or a
Bible verse that you want to share
that's just impactful to you
yeah Matthew 7 7. something I keep going
back to just for this year as we are
doing
um uh our all the stuff that has
happened just uh in this facility ask
and you shall be given to you so you can
eat shall find knock on the door shall
be open unto you and we asked we looked
we sought and and man God has blessed
yeah it was really neat uh you know my
faith was really strengthened by just
seeing how
um our supporters uh poured you know
love and support and prayers and
finances and and and helped us get this
building that that to me was amazing
that people would have that type of
generosity and um so we're I'm praising
God for the awesome audience that we
have and uh you guys are awesome thank
you for enabling us to do this work
anybody else got a special thought or
prayer or anything that that maybe
happened this last year that you want to
share that one I got one in Romans 10
10. I don't know about this you know
sometimes I like to break it down verses
in the Bible
and Mikey shared with me this this verse
Romans 10 10 says for with the heart of
man believe it into righteousness and
with the mouth confession is made into
salvation so I don't know I mean to me
salvation is very
I don't know this is very close to close
to me because it's it's like every day
you have opportunity the if you messed
up yesterday
it's like you need to confess you know
Jesus Is My Savior you know and it's
like the bible promises and all stuff
right I mean we're so busy you know
doing things in life and
trying to lose weight you know but uh it
is just something like you know in Jesus
we have
your salvation you know but it's new day
in the new every day is a new
opportunity so we can go together so
just to drive from home to here I mean
as I you know traffic freeway and all
stuff you see in the news you know you
know accidents and stuff like that but
just to know that your faith like this
morning a devotional time we were
talking about like I mean it was or
maybe earlier is like maybe my body you
know is
hurt or something like that but you fate
nobody's gonna can take your fate now so
I just want to uh I don't know this year
he was to me is like you know it's your
faith let's worry about our faith or
faithful to God no matter what because
we're we're promised that hardships are
going to come trials tribulations even
for our faith people are going to hate
us and stuff but
like you said they can take your body
they can't take your soul God wants to
give us eternal life and we just got to
stay faithful and true I know this year
for me God's really taught me a lot
about prayer intercessory prayer
claiming his promises just building a
closer relationship with him and I was
reading in First Peter one six and seven
where it said and this is not the King
James version I'll go ahead and
apologize and repent but this is easier
to understand
you are extremely happy about these
things even though
sorry A message came through you are
extremely happy about these things even
though you have to suffer different
kinds of trouble for a little while now
the purpose of these troubles is to test
your faith as fire test how genuine gold
is your faith is more precious than gold
and by passing the test it will give
praise glory and honor to God this will
happen when Jesus Christ appears again
so you know I've come to a place where I
can actually thank God for the trials of
my life because
he's kind of given me an overall view
you know seeing the big picture of
things and it's like if I have to go
through something hard to see something
good happen I'm I'm willing and I think
about a woman giving birth you know
that's got to be you probably want to
die I mean I'm sure the pain is
excruciating but 10 years when you're
looking at that child you're never
thinking like oh that was a lot of pain
I went through you're all you can focus
on is your beautiful child so that was
an encouraging verse to me
um yeah when God cursed the ground for
Adam's sake that's how the Bible
describes that it is interesting because
hardships were introduced as a means to
help us shape and mold our characters
it's a bit like Groundhog's Day right
you have this day that just kind of
repeats over and over and over again I
mean it's not like you know crazy
changes in a big big way sometimes maybe
it is but it's like these little
incremental things that you get to go
okay tomorrow you get another chance
tomorrow you get another chance and you
know if you messed up today you you keep
pushing through and you know you wake up
tomorrow and go Lord help me today and
and I think that's so true
um when everything is hunky-dory and you
don't have problems I think the growth
really comes from those challenges you
really get to see What You're Made Of
you know like do I really believe this
do I really put this to practice and
that's that's that's hard to see in a
big sense if it's not ever tested
I'm so appreciative of being a part of
something that is very fulfilling and
also where we can just openly talk about
faith talk about God have worships in
the office and encourage each other I'm
also thankful for team there is a a
verse in Ecclesiastes that says You Know
Two Is Better Than One when one fails
the other is there to lift him up and
thinking about a chord well one chord is
not strong
if you interlace three of them and make
a rope can't be broken and so um this
year well just throughout Ministry
burnout is real you know especially when
you're dealing with some pretty tough
topics but it's so fantastic when you
have multiple people working together
and um hearing different ideas making
like more solid cases coming from
different perspectives and then you're
able to reach a broader amount of people
because it's not just you and your
perspective it's other team members as
well but this year was interesting for
me because I I don't really deal with
health issues ever
but then during the summer I had a scare
with like my lymph system I had an
inflamed lymph node so yeah I'm just
thankful for a team because in having to
visit different doctors and things like
that being out of the office that
doesn't mean my responsibilities can be
put on pause but I want to thank you as
a team for stepping up you know and and
keeping the the ship moving and of
course I would do the same for any of
you so I think it's so uh profound the
statement in Ecclesiastes because the
work must go on and God has provided
each one of us to be a help to be a
source of encouragement in that time and
people are so appreciative of our
ministry and the consistency of it you
know that wasn't there like maybe five
years ago and so to see where we have
come from even when I first arrived four
years ago I think we were putting out uh
videos like once every three weeks or
something yeah yeah when we decided to
go to once a week that was like oh I
don't know if we can do that you know
but it's been going on
over two years at least one video a week
and that's that's no small task and I
just praise God for how he's he's just
kept us strong and faithful all this
time beautiful
how about you Brad or Keith
you know I'm just I'm just happy to have
a a great job and a great set of people
to work with I mean I think that's it
and we have um able to talk just like
most people have said here able to talk
about Christ anytime have worships in
the morning and uh and just just to
continue to flow through that that's
just amazing I think yeah it is neat to
have multiple people's
um you know different creative Styles
and stuff and and playing together and
to me it's like I I remember praying
years ago like I just I want a team Lord
help me to like have some people and
it's like God answered this in 10 times
more than I could have ever imagined him
to answer it and and so I I share this
exact same sentiments like it is really
neat to see all of us gel together and
and create some stuff it's been a fun
year and it didn't happen overnight yeah
and good things are worth waiting for
and that's what God is teaching me too
about patience and wait on him looking
at stories like Abraham not getting his
son right away and Joseph being in the
pit and he's not Prince of Egypt or
whatever you know it's just like things
take time but God has a plan and he's
working in the natural he's not like
Supernatural like you got a team
overnight you know I feel like he gives
us what we need for the season because
it just seems like things are ramping up
there's so much to cover so much to talk
about could you imagine having to handle
all of that when it was just like three
of you yeah no it just wouldn't happen
so yeah it's neat
how about you Keith
I
um I don't make any New Year's
resolutions and
the reason I don't do that is because I
guess I'm more
I don't know I don't I don't I don't
want to compare myself to other people
so I'm not going to say what I was going
to say
um
it's not me and the reason it's not me
is because I feel I I think that when it
comes time to making a decision you need
to make the decision then and not wait
there you go if you're waiting for New
Year's it may be too late
there are many people who thought they
had tomorrow and they didn't
and so you know I'm reminded of what it
says in Hebrews 3 and 4 over and over
again it uses this language where it
says you know
um
today if you hear his voice
and then it you know I was talking about
something else like not hardening your
heart or whatever but I think the theme
is the same it's a call to make a
decision today because today is the only
day that you know that you have and some
people don't even make it to the end of
the day yeah
right so
um
you know I like candy I went through a
very challenging
experience about this time last year and
it was significant enough that I didn't
know if I was going to be able to
continue to work
and I'm still dealing with some of the
effects of that but it really drove home
that I don't have any guarantees in this
life
don't have any guarantees about tomorrow
I don't have any
um I don't have any guarantees about
anything your life can change that fast
and that's kind of a scary thing
sometimes when you think about it you
know if you were faced with some medical
issue and it was like
okay you may not be able to work the
rest of your life I know your wife has
to work to support your family that's
kind of a big thing
um so yeah don't put off the important
decisions is what I would say don't wait
for things like New Year's or your
birthday or whatever make the decision
today and especially when it concerns
the things of Christ you may be
wrestling with a decision
don't wait that's what the Bible says do
it today well said and yeah Good Counsel
you and I think you'll appreciate a
couple of these other slides that I'm
going to show you because it's going to
tie into exactly what you just said go
for it Brittany
let's hear about your life this last
year
[Laughter]
uh what was the question
because I know we were talking about
resolutions and we're talking about oh
yeah it's just a moment of growth or you
know how did this last year go as you're
reflecting on the previous year anything
stick out in your mind that was just
like I'm really glad that I that I had
that experience or that I grew from that
experience and maybe it's not something
you wanted but you came out the other
side better
um I think something that has been a
point of growth for me especially in my
spiritual life is like God has been
teaching me how to wait on him
and I think
like one example is like for my baptism
I prayed for like eight months for a
place to get baptized I wanted to be out
in nature
um and you know doing it in a church
would have been easier but I have always
connected with God in nature so I
remember just looking at different
national parks around Tennessee but then
I have like people in my family who
can't like walk that far and then it was
just inconvenient for people to drive
out there and then on top of that it's
it's a public area so people could just
be playing any kind of music and anyway
um God ended up like towards like maybe
the last three weeks right before I was
about to get baptized he ended up
choosing a place for me led me to it and
I ended up getting baptized in a wedding
venue that was like on 120 acres and it
was really beautiful and you guys were
there and tell them how much it was yeah
three three
they gave it to you yeah yeah I ended up
I remember that morning because I was
part of a week of prayer
and then they had a next step program
like on Sabbath and I remember thinking
this has nothing to do with me I'm like
I have a whole separate job like I'm not
with the school at any point so there's
no reason for me to go but I just really
felt the Holy Spirit like
you know just prompt me to go and I
remember not setting my alarm that
morning because I didn't want to but I
ended up waking early on waking up early
on time and I had a friend who I had met
at the week of prayer called me and said
hey are you going and I was like I mean
I'm already up so I guess because she
offered a ride and then I ended up being
prayer partners with the owner of the
venue and then I told them what was he
was like the question was like what is
God doing in your life what is he
calling you to do next and I was just
telling him you know like I feel called
to be baptized but I'm just struggling
with trying to find a place he said why
don't you pick one of the ponds that we
have here and then what's interesting
too is the date that we that I had
picked for my baptism was the date that
his like the whole venue was going to be
blocked off because usually there's like
five weddings happening that day but it
was blocked off because his daughter was
getting married so I had like there was
no rush to be out at a certain time no
one had to worry about me being in the
background of their pictures no
inconvenience especially since it was
free and other people would been paying
like 30 grand or more to have a wedding
there so just all of it I've just
learned like if it's not happening right
now just to wait for God's best
beautiful you know I didn't even
consider because it was such a beautiful
day I remember going out there the the
sky was blue yeah I mean the sun was out
it was absolutely gorgeous and I didn't
even think about it it's a wedding venue
yeah like like you're you are literally
getting married to to your relationship
with Jesus and and what a beautiful
story to to have a huge milestone in
your life and and thank you for inviting
us to be a part of that yeah that's
awesome every everything went perfectly
it's like God was taking care of every
little dude every little bit when we
were there because it was quite a few
people it was geese all around all that
cracking and all that we'll do a Greek
geese quack anyway yeah
um and then right as you were about to
get baptized it just disappeared yeah
and then as soon as she went into the
water and came back up and we were
talking all the geese just came back
again yeah they just kind of stayed on
the side like they didn't even just swim
behind they just kind of stayed at the
side and where'd all those chairs come
from did they provide all that they
provided that that's amazing I imagine
the Angels were just holding their beaks
you know
right now what's interesting is they
didn't show up in any of the pictures
that's true they didn't show up in any
of the pictures
God's taking care of things that we
can't control that's right so so
beautiful things you guys this is this
is really an inspiration to hear you
know some of these moments that that you
learned something valuable waiting on
the Lord and and you know like I love
what Keith said not to make you know a
resolution that's just specifically on
this because everybody else is doing it
and I need to do it on this day so I I
said I would tie it back into your
thought how long do you think people
keep the New Year's resolutions two
weeks oh yes I would say two weeks two
weeks two weeks according to my gym
membership yeah about a month a month
I've seen I mean like the the packed
it's packed parking lot for like a month
and then that's about it are we all that
weak-minded and we're pretty weak
vessels right okay so here is some of
the statistics coming from the New York
Post the average American abandons their
New Year's resolution by this date
February everyone wow so you were right
one month yeah February 1st we call it
quits on our New Year's resolution says
the article
um uh they put did a poll of 2 000
Americans and they found just in 32 days
the average person finally breaks their
resolution well I thought it only took
21 days to create a habit so what's
going on I know I know what's going on
Wow apparently they weren't they weren't
doing things over and over again during
those times 68 of uh those that reported
the resolutions um they broke it even
sooner than that so we're talking like
that that that's not even everybody that
makes it to there so you're probably
correct two weeks is probably the
average of what people yeah 68 of them
more than half don't even make it to
February first yeah and I've definitely
like my birthday is February 6th so I
usually on February 6 I'm like okay I'll
just start over on my birthday it's a
new year and that's why I love that my
birthday's so early on but I have
definitely fallen into this and I think
part of the reason too is because
sometimes I set resolutions that are
they're too many like I set like 20 and
then it's really hard to keep up or I
don't have anyone to do them with two is
better than one accountability they
actually they actually did say
accountability if you tell people your
resolution you're actually more likely
to keep it so we're gonna do that at the
end yeah I don't know if I want to tell
everybody so are we telling everybody
our resume today
and I'll let you know how it's going in
fact one in seven Americans actually
believe
um that they they're they're not going
to even follow through in the in the
first place isn't that crazy they don't
have faith in them faith in themselves
look at look at what this article also
says the top reason that people don't
stick to their resolutions is lack of
self-discipline yeah that makes sense
what are the fruits of the spirit
self-control is one of them self-control
is one of them right followed by busy
schedules lacking in proper time to see
them through lacking in time think about
this guys we've been hammering at this
use of time for how many years now
wasting time on unprofitable things over
and over and over again video games
social media movies You Name It We waste
a lot of time in our culture and that we
can't even get to the things that we
really need to help change and if if I
can speak just personally of my own
experience notice how none of those Had
To Do With God all those lists you can't
fix something without the help of God
truly fix it so you know I think that I
wish that God was on the top of
everyone's list I hope it's on the top
of your guys's list this next year two
in five
um also believe that societal and peer
pressure are a big reason that their
resolutions are cut short so even as an
adult we still deal with peer pressure
did they talk about uh the top reason
because I would think it would either
fall between
um lack of structure or Preparation lack
of having a plan or a Next Step because
I could say I want to lose weight then I
don't make a shopping list to correct
what I buy and purchase for my meals
even when Jesus was healing people he
always gave a next step Sin no more uh
uh that's interesting because you know
at our church we have this weight loss
program that we do every year starting
in January and it's called best way and
it's like a 10-week program
people go through it but what I what
I've noticed about people
is that
we're creatures of habit so when it
comes time to change
everything's a barrier
like even you know something that's put
on me like okay I know if I'm going to
lose weight I have to follow this plan
and the plan is laid out before you okay
these are the things that you should eat
this is the exercise that you should do
et cetera Etc it's laid out for you but
people will be resistant because they're
like well yeah I see the foods that I
have to eat but I don't have a meal plan
or
I can't just go get that at the store I
normally go to
or what have you and so you have to
remove barriers for people you have to
make it like as easy as possible
otherwise they they don't you know they
don't make that jump do you think it
could also be that people drive
themselves to exhaustion like they put
their like let's say if your goal is to
lose weight and then you're eating all
these foods and then you're going to the
gym like five times a week and it's just
too much rather than easing your way
into it do you think that that could be
another thing they might just burn out
just by observation what I notice is
most of the people that come our middle
aged or older
a lot of them their kids are out of the
house it's down to the the two people
that the family started with
um they're approaching retirement age
and if they're not already there
and their lives have changed where the
usually the lady is the one that cooks
not always but if she was doing that and
she was doing that for you know four to
six people or more she hasn't been doing
that for years you know we just we buy
the easy things at the store because
there's only two of us and and so
cooking kind of just goes by the wayside
right and so it's like you don't cook
anymore so now if you're asking people
to make their own food again it's like
well no that's a barrier it's it's more
difficult than what I'm doing now I can
just go get something there's all kinds
of things it's it takes effort to meet
your goals it really does I I wonder
if you didn't have a list of things to
do what if you had one
what if you just put one on your list I
I'm not going to get overwhelmed I just
want to focus on this one thing and see
what happens and and for me
um I I really do I I I want to make a
consistent
um you know sometimes my schedule's all
over the place and and but I want to to
work on my consistency of timing with
when I wake up and and have my devotion
time sometimes it's kind of all over the
board and and I need to be better about
that and that's one thing that I'm
really praying to God like you know give
me this just today just tomorrow yes I
did this morning so yeah but uh I want
to read to you a couple of verses
go ahead and read this Mikey so Proverbs
24 16 says for the righteous falls seven
times and rises again but the wicked
stumble in times of Calamity so what
does that verse mean I think it means
when you've we're all going to fall
we're like we're just we we get tempted
we get overwhelmed or whatever we fall
into something but don't stay down don't
say well I guess I I smoked might as
well become a smoker again no stop again
quit again
um you know so when you fall get back up
you might fall again get back up keep
keep trying to get back up yeah stay
down the one important thing I forgot to
mention in all of that was the thing
that the participants are taught it
leads to us something kindy was saying
and I think or it might have been you
Scotty they're all taught the the secret
and source of their power as trusting
God
so it's not that you know you're going
to be the one doing it and making it and
all that because we're all weak human
beings you know like this it's like yeah
you fall down who how are you getting
back up you're getting up with help yeah
right like a parent lifting their little
kid up yeah so I think it's interesting
that
um Solomon used the word the righteous
false I just just ponder that for a
second because I think part of the
problem of people not keeping their New
Year's resolutions too is failure and
when you fail do you just get frustrated
and give up I can't do this I'm done and
I'm going to go back to my old ways but
look at what it says somebody that
really is determined I I remember I
worked on on The Biggest Loser and it
was really interesting to see those
people come into the room with 500
pounds and and in the very first day
when they'd come on the show they talk
about what they'd eat these people would
eat like four cheeseburgers on their way
to work they'd be drinking diet coke all
day they'd go home and they'd have I
mean it was like the amount of money
they spent was incredible also the grace
of God yeah on their health and you
could actually put that in your food in
your body and still live is
mind-boggling but but what was awesome
was they would just try again and again
and again on the show to lose weight and
they'd get up they'd be frustrated but
we're getting up today and we're doing
it again and over the course of time
that persistency you saw those people
drop down to 160 pounds and it was
amazing
something
you also said about that show was people
who fought to lose that weight
kept it off longer than the people that
take the magic pill get the the what are
the laptops stapled and stuff those
people because it was like overnight fix
they fall right back into it which makes
me think about that's why God allows us
to take so long that's right because if
he fixes it overnight if he Parts the
waters you're gonna be worshiping the
calf on the other side what if they had
to swim across that ocean
maybe they wouldn't work yeah yeah so
yeah this presents an interesting
contrast and I'm also thinking about the
preparation that's presented in this
verse because it says the righteous fall
seven times and Rises so this is a
continual thing as if they're improving
they're getting better at it so they're
not falling as much but in contrast with
the righteous it says the wicked stumble
in times of Calamity as if to say that
the righteous aren't able to not stumble
in times of Calamity because of the
preparation they did before like in the
moment you get stronger when it counts
the wicked stumble but because the
righteous have been falling But Rising
again in that specific time of Calamity
they may not fall yeah training anybody
ever done an Iron Man no what an iron
man yeah the one where you run bikes
or something yeah yeah yeah like those
people don't just walk out of their
house and do that right I mean you you I
I've seen people train for that and I
mean you get sore sick tired this that
but but that persistency that
persistence help helps them achieve that
goal look at it like it's Tony Hawk or
something you drop in like this imagine
how many times he felt yeah he could
have said well I can't do this I'm not a
skater you keep falling you keep trying
I got one more verse to read to you here
uh okay candy go ahead and read this
verse sure song chapter 46 verses 1 and
2 says God is our refuge and strength a
very present help in trouble therefore
we will not fear even though the Earth
is removed and though the mountains be
carried into the midst of the sea now
you don't get
that kind of stability
unless you've prepared with trials if
the mountains are being tossed into the
ocean that's going to be a very fearful
thing but if you are not moved by that
Supernatural experience that's happening
if you could trace back over the course
of people's lives and see how many times
they stumbled how many times they fell
how many times they picked themselves up
and kept going forward and I love how it
is God that gave you the strength God
helped you through that that moment
so that was it I just wanted to share
those things with you guys and um I
think some really beautiful things came
out of this conversation
um trusting in God waiting on God and
just like Keith mentioned making that
choice today not January 1st you know
it's like today if you're watching this
video six months down the road
um you need to make this decision while
you still have an opportunity to do that
and you won't be sorry so we thank you
guys for all the love and support that
you have shared with us it has been a
wonderful year for Little Light Studios
next year keep us in your prayers we
have something that we are trying to
achieve and we are raising 250 000 for
our ministry to be able to put an LED
wall in which will make all these
creative things that we do work much
faster and better and so keep us in your
prayers and if you guys want to share
this video like support reach out to us
tell us how you've been impacted by
Little Light Studios but we we have been
impacted by you guys and we thank you
for all the love and support that you've
given to us thus far and we hope you
have a wonderful year
bye
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
I don't know
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
foreign
[Music]